my co-pilot today is NFL superstar and
very good friend of our show Brandon
Marshall
the best I miss you I miss you too I
love it you normally we're playing games
you're reffing we're talking about your
charity we're doing so many things but
today we news we're doing news all right
you got the most exciting Brandon are
you guys ready oh yeah we're ready okay
here we go first up today's reports
Kourtney Kardashian Barker sparked a
heated debate when she posted a photo on
Instagram of food all over her bathroom
floor even on top of her toilet Drew is
it okay to have a buffet in a picnic
about a toilet
it's so funny because I think a bathtub
like somehow in water is like the one
place that I'm not hungry it's like
finally like if I just lived in a tub
I'd be on a great diet
there's something appetite suppressing
about water to me well you know what I
just think she did a little too much
because I'm actually okay with eating in
a tub if it stays in the fruit category
but when you get like
it was too much so it's like the Savory
Foods yeah
um all right next up Sports illustrator
reports that former Los Angeles Dodger
outfielder Andrew toles hasn't played
since 2018 largely due to struggles with
his mental health but the Dodgers
continue to keep him under contract so
that he has access to health insurance
and continuous mental health support
Brandon you're the founder and CEO of
House of athlete plus which is an app
that we talk about often on the show
because it's dedicated to improving the
physical and mental health of athletes
what did you think of this story well
first I want to say if
more leagues and teams were embracing
this house of athlete plus wouldn't
exist right
um
athletes and artists
for forever have set Trends in fads and
I just pray that this conversation
starts a trend and fed and trickles down
into other Industries how are we
approaching insurance so this is a big
deal like I'm really excited about this
2011 I was diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder I spent three
months in an outpatient program and that
was the first thing that came to my mind
we got to walk the halls of Congress we
got to testify in front of Congress to
actually allocate the right resources to
floor things like this
this touches all of us this is the next
big thing that we got to take on well
when the news team found this story we
knew that we had to talk about it with
you next have you ever had a first date
with someone who immediately dives into
heavy topics like their hopes and fears
the meaning of life but doesn't ask you
a single question oh you had me until
you're not asking back well stylist has
a term for that it's called Deep dumping
um and it's when your date skips the
small talk goes into deep personal
philosophies
um Brandon have you ever deep dumped on
a date you're a deep dude have you ever
deep dumped
um you know what yes I am a deep dumper
you are I hate to say it I'm a d dumper
I'm the I'm the guy that's sitting there
in the first date I don't care what's
going on I want to go deep right away I
need to know we just talked about mental
health yeah what have you been through
yeah what's going on I want to know
everything so there's times where I'm
doing all the talking and then my dates
like
um well let me tell you how I feel like
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah go ahead so
I have to catch myself sometimes right
so I'm a deep dumper I hate to admit it
I find
um which you know is I think what I'm
attracted to I don't even know at this
point but
um I I sometimes say I don't want
marriage or kids you know I I've been
down that road I've lived that life and
it was incredible and positive and I'm
so fulfilled I don't even know if I want
to live with someone again maybe I'm
open to it I don't know why not how does
that strike straight men on a date
is that like repellent or is that like a
relief I guess it depends on where
you're at in life I love it you're
literally raising your man's hand right
there okay go sick of Joey what does the
straight male think about that the Stray
male thinks that can we wait until
date three to have this conversation I
think for the most part I mean right
right away it's talking about kids
talking about I think it's important
because you laid on the table but I also
think it's it could be a little
overwhelming even if it's I don't want
it
yeah because that's a very firm like
statement and then it's like can we talk
about it can we have a conversation
about it and coming in that strong off
the top sometimes that could be a little
bit oh that it could be intimidating
okay just throwing it out there okay
what's your name uh Sean
thank you Sean you're welcome that's why
I like this whole conversation about
deep thumping right now you have to it
has it has to be healthy where you
actually ask someone a question like Hey
how do you feel about this you can't
just dominate the conversation but
you've got to peel back the layers and I
think that's what Sean's saying I think
there's a perfect pretty little middle
between the both of you where it's like
make it a conversation not a decree
right out of the gate that's right oh my
God I'm going to soften my edges thank
you that's great
oh my god well
Sean thank you Brandon thank you you
have our last story and I'm gonna thank
right now here we go
Synergy so important
finally Entertainment Tonight Canada
reports singer Sean Mendes is a big fan
of an unexpected fashion statement crop
tops for men Drew thoughts on men
showing some man riff
not there's never too soon for that
really no so you feel good about that I
love a crop on a man so on your first
date you go out
deep dumping he's deep dumping in a crop
top right you're sitting there your
favorite pizza place in Brooklyn no you
don't know he has a crop top on he gets
up say I have to go to the bathroom he
takes off his off his Blazer and he has
a crop top on what do you do
what do you do
[Music]
[Applause]
um Brandon is sticking around a co-pilot
the whole show need I say more
[Music]